أه أحد المتحدثين باسم
الجيش الإسرائيلي العقيد لارنر قال إنهم
في الأساس سيحملون حكومتك
أه المسؤولية عن أي هجوم من زوج
أريدك فقط أن تستمع إلى هذا
وأريد أن أعطيك فرصة للرد
هنا
إنها حكومة  لبنان أي شيء
يحدث من
أراضيه السيادية يحتاجون إليه وهم
مسؤولون عنه
وسيحاسبون على ذلك فهي
دولة ذات سيادة ولها سيطرة على حدودها
وعليهم مسؤولية التأكد من أن
الإرهابيين مثل حزب الله
والجيش الإرهابي لا يطلقون النار  الهجمات
ضد إسرائيل لقد وضعوا
هذه المسؤولية عليك يا سيدي وزير الخارجية،
أعلم أنهم قالوا أكثر من ذلك
قالوا سوف أه لو يعيدون لبنان
إلى العصر الحجري وهكذا، كما تعلم إذا
توقفوا فأنت تعلم أنه لا أحد يتحدث في
لبنان حتى  الحسا لا يقول
أي شيء في لبنان، كما تعلمون أن
زعيم الحسبة لم يدلي
بتصريح بعد، إذا توقفوا عن الحديث، فهؤلاء
يحرضون على الوضع، إنهم
يجعلونه ينجح من خلال كلامهم، لذلك من
الأفضل لهم أن يدعوا إلى
رابطة الدول المستقلة حقًا.  أطلقوا النار، لذا فهم دولة
والآخرون ميليشيات، لذا دعنا نعرف
دعونا نستدعي مولى ونرى ما
سيحدث بدلاً من التهديد،
لا توجد طريقة للتهديد الآن لأن
الضرر سيكون أسوأ بالنسبة
لهم بقدر ما بالنسبة لنا، كما تعلمون  سيكون
لبنان هو ما نخشى أن يتضرر ويدمر،
لكن
بلدهم لن يكون آمنًا
لأن كل قوى المقاومة هذه
لديها الكثير من الأسلحة وسوف
يستخدمونها، انظر يا سيدي الوزير، أنت
حذرت قبل عدة أشهر فقط أه أنه
نظرا لانهيار
الحكومة في لبنان ليس
لديها رئيس حاليا أنه إذا
حدث انهيار أكثر يمكن أن
يكون الوضع أسوأ على حد تعبيرك
ومن الذي بين إسرائيل و
الفلسطينيين الآن يجب أن أسألكم أن
هناك الكثير من الناس ينظرون
إلى حكومتكم الآن
وينتقدونها لأنها في النهاية ليس لها رأي في
ما إذا كانت بلادكم في سلام أو
في حالة حرب أه وأن هذه في
الأساس دعوة  مجموعة شبه عسكرية
ستقوم بها هيئة غير منتخبة في
نهاية المطاف، وأتساءل ما الذي
ستقوله لهذا
النقد، أود أن أقول إنه ليس
لبنان فقط، بل كل دولة في المنطقة، إذا
ساء الوضع في غزة،
فلن تضطر كل دولة في المنطقة إلى ذلك
يقول الكثير أن كل حكومة في
المنطقة لن يكون لها رأي كبير فيما
يحدث في الشارع أو على
الحدود مع إسرائيل، فالوضع ليس سهلاً ويجب على
الإسرائيليين أن
يفهموا أن حكومات هذه
المنطقة بما في ذلك حكومة لبنان على الرغم من
حقيقة أننا  ليس لدينا رئيس لا
نريد الحرب لا نريد أن نرى
الدمار في بلداننا ولكن إذا
خرجت الأمور عن السيطرة فالله وحده يعلم ماذا
سيحدث ليس لنا فقط ولا
لدول المنطقة ولإسرائيل
أيضاً  لذلك من الأفضل السيطرة عليها في
غزة لأن الناس
هنا مترابطون سياسيًا وحتى دمويًا، لذا لا
يمكننا منعهم من القيام ببعض
الانتقام إذا كان الوضع في
غزة سيكون أسوأ مما هو عليه
الآن، مما يعني أنه لا يمكنك الصمود.  لقد عاد
هذا ما
تقوله الآن نحن نتحاور إنهم لا
يريدون الحرب حسنًا، نحن لا نريد الحرب
ولكن أعني أنك لا تستطيع السيطرة عليها، كل هذا
يتوقف مرة أخرى على ما يحدث في غزة على
غزو إسرائيل لغزة